Bruce Arians now of CBSsports here on
the Rich Eisen show how are you Bruce
I'm doing great rich how're you doing
buddy where are you calling it from what
do I get six a lake in Georgia alright
so you're you're not yet on the road for
your game yet this week correct
no yeah head out seven o'clock tonight
where you going which game you doing
this exact Giants and Titans that is a
big one for the Titans Bruce right I
mean they gotta have it and so do the
Giants you know it's kind of they're
still there alright so Bruce Arians here
in the Honda inside a report on the Rich
Eisen show what are you seeing from the
Titans what did you see looking at the
film I guess against Jacksonville that
we really hadn't seen from Derek Henry
all year long Bruce what do you what do
you think of the Titans viability as a
playoff team here yeah I like them you
know mainly because they're defense and
they can run the football
yeah it was kind of a breakout game for
Derek Henry I guess not even 60 yards
and any other game us on you pop out
with over 200 and obviously the 99
yarder about five stiff arms were pretty
impressive but he's that type of back
they have a hill Marcus mariota's
playing better it's a big game for them
because he hasn't played well on a road
all year and you know obviously Houston
sitting at the top of that heap and you
know the division intimately from your
time with the cult's when you see Andrew
Luck and what you're seeing from Andrew
Luck this year as good as ever
correct would you say it looked he looks
just like the guy that you were interim
coaching back in the day Bruce oh I
don't think there's any doubt rich I
mean that's my wow that's my wild card
team right now if somehow they get in
you know that road when at Houston
that's like a playoff win so they're
already playoff tested if they can get
in they're going to be tough so you like
them out of the entire on the outside
looking in the hunt yeah right now
succeed you know I think that I hope
that game comes down to the you know
Tennessee versus the Colts for a playoff
picture I think that'd be a great game
yeah that's week 17 that's week 17 right
now what do you think of our poll
question which team currently six seed
on down in the NFC is the best chance
to make it as the succeed right now I
don't think it'll matter they'll be the
first ones out to go into Chicago
essentially or Dallas and winning that
first playoff game oh not I mean they
could be seven and nine whoever gets it
her at eight six and one or whatever it
is I mean it's very easy I would have
always said Minnesota but their defense
didn't show up last week hasn't shown up
for few Kirk Cousins obviously the
object a potential problems oh you never
count out Aaron Rodgers but I mean that
there's just no one there if the Giants
pull off this upset they could sneak in
mm-hmm although their favorite in this
day they are I mean because of the way
that sake wons been running Bruce
Aaron's here on the Rich Eisen show
let's get into some other storylines in
the NFL
Bruce Honda insider report Bruce Arians
to the best of your ability what do you
think happened with Ben Roethlisberger
on that sideline and just no one been as
you do or what's going on within that
locker room it always seems like there's
something we don't know about with Ben
or what's going on in that locker room
what do you think happened with him in
the rib injury and the x-ray not being
readable and he comes out and he stands
around but then goes back in what do you
think happened I you know I would have
to think it was something to do with the
doctors and trainers during that time
trying to get a viable answer on what
was wrong knowing Ben he's saying I'm
good to go and somebody was holding him
back us I mean I don't think I really
wanted to see the other quarterback play
that much so I mean that was a big loss
for them is that what happens on the
sidelines is that where someone comes to
you as the HD and says we don't know and
you look at the the quarterback who's
standing there after he jogs in and and
I mean walk me through what happens on a
sideline where that yeah I mean I mean
normally it's with concussion protocol
or
the trainer will come up and say so and
so's out I said we meet out he's out for
a moment what we're going to get back
there he's not in he's not out totally
and then you just go on coaching and let
that up to the doctors and trainers and
then they'll come back say he's good to
go and that was baffling and I know John
Orr was one of the best trainers and dr.
Bradley one of the best doctors in the
league so it is a really weird scenario
he was really weird and then you know
I'm wondering what's going on in that
locker room with with this team now on
the brink against New England what is
tomlin like in these situations best you
might very very calm very calm doesn't
blink goes to the next game you know I
wouldn't be surprised to see the
Steelers play the best game of the year
that's the way they are they love drama
they sure do
Bruce Arians here in the Honda insider
report what is the challenge now in
Minnesota changing an offensive
coordinator with three weeks to go what
do you think the Vikings offense is
going to look like differently Bruce I
don't whether you can't change what
you're doing but you can change the
number of running plays versus number
pass place and I think that when I saw
Mike summers face on the short yardage
play they threw the ball and it was like
it's over you know and I think Kevin's
gonna go in and I think they'll run try
to establish the run to get that passing
game going so what do you mean by it's
over I could just tell is over for John
D Filippo when I saw my face when he
didn't run that ball no kidding
that's that's the siren that yeah just
looking at my camera going Boop it's
he's had enough have you ever given a
coach that look Bruce in college at
temple I fired my guys every week I
would fire one or two of them every week
not after the game would have it there
okay that's good it's good so Freddie
kitchens your guy that's now core
the offense in Cleveland for for Baker
Mayfield what has he done do you think
to unlock and unleash the number one
overall pick in a way that was unable to
be unlocked sustainably they've got a
great rapport she's given Baker a lot of
input and when you let your quarterback
come in and pick plays and have input
what adds to his accountability he feels
a part of it he took like it's his
offense Freddie's done a great job
that's what we've always done with all
our quarterbacks when I went back and
coached him at Alabama
it was I hey what do you like what don't
you like tell me what you don't like so
I don't call that and they just have a
great rapport every play that's coming
in Baker likes it and well he was really
impressive in the second half of Houston
when we had them couple weeks ago after
throwing three picks in the first half
and then coming out for throwing over
350 and a second half really impressive
so it's amazing that I'll be honest with
you Bruce when a fan hears what you just
said that it's might be as simple as
just asking the quarterback what do you
like what don't you like how does
something like that not happen I mean
why wouldn't whatever might have been
going on between Hugh Jackson and Todd
Haley why wouldn't when you have now
turned things over to your number one
overall draft choice why wouldn't you go
ahead and ask that and install plays
that he likes or is comfortable with
well I think some guys they have a game
plan they make their script of first 15
or 20 plays they'll give it to the
quarterback and tell him this is it now
if you don't like one take it out it's
not this is it except not everybody says
give me your best 15 passes and then on
Saturday night give me a red zone plays
give me your goal line plays give me a
short Lord give you your home run place
and it's just a different feel for a
quarterback when he has that
accountability not everybody just it's
kind of crazy to me all right Bruce I
want to ask you about you know obviously
you and your future you know I read
from Cleveland that you have you know
told reporters on the record you'd be
interested in the Cleveland Browns job
is that still the case
yeah I'd love to listen to what mr.
Dorsey mr. Haslam had to say I've always
had this fondness for Cleveland and I
wanted that job almost every time I came
open I never got an interview so I
thought I'll get one this time - why are
you doubt that I don't know I just it
was it was just one of those things a
reporter asked me and you know I got it
got some it got some gas and but I
haven't denied it well so let's let me
walk through this one by one then if you
don't mind what do you like about
Cleveland what's what is your affinity
towards the number one the number one
thing riches they're fans just think
back that was an awful I don't know it's
your stretch I mean I was there when we
went to the playoffs and should it be
Pittsburgh and but even since then you
go to Browns game it's full I mean
they're they're cheering like crazy and
they went with three and fifty or
whatever it was some crazy number the
last few years and and when I did the
first game this year Pittsburgh
Cleveland the tie in the rain I mean
they were going nuts to the last second
of overtime went back and same thing I
mean just it's great fans well I mean
their fans are great in Green Bay - you
know I'm just and you got someone like
Aaron Rodgers sitting out there or would
you be would you I read that you were
not interested in that job but he's not
really yeah that's true
why true just yeah I enjoy what I'm
going down and Cleveland was probably
the only one I I would have thought
about coming out for okay so obviously
the the the dots makes sense you know
Freddie kitchens is essentially your guy
Baker Mayfield is the type of guy that I
think you know your sensibilities and
nature would mesh well with so why do
you think you wouldn't even get
interview is it because you're talking
about it publicly Bruce I probably just
because you know I've been asked about
it and not politicking for it to say I'd
love to listen and just so they would
know but you know it's it's um I
wouldn't be surprised of great weight
and letting get a job as good at jobs
he's doing right now
sure did you was it awkward prior to
calling a game when you see a song but
Greg and I are friends for a long long
long time
so did you say anything to him or him to
you no we just went on we did our jobs
okay you did your jobs last one for you
on this subject then coach when you were
here last time in person when you were
kind enough to stop by the show you were
saying that coaching was something in
your blood obviously but you had to give
it up in a way because you were
concerned about even getting a heart
attack on the sidelines that doesn't
concern you anymore potentially I know
I've gotten such a good clean bill of
health alas this this year off
especially other than gaining about ten
more pounds no at that part of it and I
how if I went back I wouldn't I would
not call place and I would turn it over
to one of the guys I've trained and so
that would feel very comfortable that
way which takes a lot of the stress out
of it okay hey coach really appreciate
you calling in and join your call with
with Greg Gumbel and Trent green you
have a great cast in in New Jersey and a
big game for the Titans and as you point
out the Giants as well yes a great one
it should blow tide you got it a coach
best to you and your family and you got
it right back at you that's Bruce Arians
at Bruce Arians on Twitter the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience